gang
we're going back to westeros i thought
you were dead
not yet nearly two years after the game
of thrones series finale
we have our first look at hbo's highly
anticipated prequel series
house of the dragon it's pretty
awe-inspiring
here's what we know i am daenerys
stormborn
of house targaryen the spin-off is set
300 years before the events of the
original series
and as the title suggests we'll focus on
house targaryen
making this family the ancestors of
queen khaleesi
there was a lot of blood there was a lot
of blood the show is an adaptation of
george r.r martin's 2018 novel
fire and blood and the best-selling
writer is also
co-creator of the series you always hope
for
that the work you do will be popular
will be
well received but there was no way for
anybody to anticipate the scale of
popularity has happened with uh
with game of thrones or with my books
which are
are now in 48 languages around the world
that's pretty mind-blowing too
i'm aiming for 50 though i want to want
a nice round 50. we need two more
languages
among the mostly british ensemble is the
crown's matt
smith trading one royal court for
another as
prince damon targaryen younger brother
to the king
and heir to the titular throne
he's also described as possessing the
true blood of the dragon
let's see how that works out i'm not
going to stop the wheel
i'm going to break the wheel the new
photos also tease characters from actors
emma deyarsi steve tucson olivia cook
and rhys iphones house of the dragon is
set to debut
in 2022 on hbo and hbo max
where are my dragons but the got
expansion
doesn't stop there at hbo we're
developing
a number of successor shows to game of
thrones
yes the network also has three
additional spinoffs currently
in development as the original game of
thrones series came to an end
george rr martin told et how he feels
about the franchise's massive success
here we are at the final season premiere
of game of thrones what does this mean
to you to see your legacy come to
fruition like this
you know i never could have predicted
you know
you you sell a project and first says oh
my god will it actually get shot oh my
god they made a pilot would i pick it up
to series
oh will anybody watch it it'll be over
in one season you know and then
it just snowballs and snowballs and
every answer there is yes and
it's it's pretty astonishing it boggles
your mind